[Musik]
verschiedene menschen stehen hier an den
trümmern ihrer existenz
die häuser weggespült ich musste mit den
tränen kämpfen haben uns ist alles so
schön macht also ich meine wohnung
verließ hatte ich das wasser schon bis
hierhin stehen
ich hatte keine chance es zu rücken da
kam eine ältere dame mir entgegen können
kennen sie jemand der mir helfen kann
ich sage ja ich komme was los da so
viele leute die jetzt hier sind spontan
helfen
er sei überwältigend ja stimmen aus
denen eine tragödie spricht die
deutschland so noch nicht erlebt hat und
damit guten abend und willkommen zum zdf
spezial
vier tage ist es her dass wassermassen
wie von sinnen über teile des landes
hereingebrochen sind die schäden die sie
angerichtet haben lassen sich längst
nicht vollständig begreifen
allem voran der verlust von
menschenleben aber auch der materielle
verlust wenn die hochwassergeschädigten
vor den trümmern ihrer existenz stehen
in welchen fällen sie mit finanzieller
hilfe rechnen können auch das wollen wir
in dieser sendung besprechen so denkst
aber simone müller über eine katastrophe
deren ausmaße von tag zu tag sichtbar
und auch unerträglicher werden
altena früher ein kleinod im aartal
brücken strassen häuser alles kaputt
doch für jacob k j der hier ein kleines
hotel betreibt zählt nur eins das ist
das wie ich es gibt genug leute die in
demmin nicht mehr
seit drei tagen räumen sie auf was noch
aufzuräumen ist das haus neben ihn gibt
es nicht mehr
wir haben nachbarn ein altes gemauertes
bruchsteinen haus die saßen im haus und
die tochter zugeguckt wie das haus mit
den leuten weg gestanden ist das bislang
schlimmste hochwasser ist fünf jahre her
kein vergleich zu dem was letzten
mittwoch hier passierte das stieg
innerhalb von kürzester zeit so schnell
unglaublich unglaublich was da für
baumstämme was da gelegt worden ist hier
legten 7 halb tonner lkw
keiner weiß ob nicht auch noch menschen
unter den trümmern liegen
seit gestern sind sie mit suchhunden
unterwegs einsatzkräfte aus allen teilen
in rheinland pfalz in erftstadt ahrem in
nordrhein westfalen ist das wasser der
ersten flutwelle noch nicht abgepumpt
und immer noch haben die menschen angst
vor weiteren überschwemmungen
das haus seines nachbarn johann plus
ebenfalls voll gelaufen
der 81 jährige weiß gar nicht wo er
anfangen soll und versucht der sache
etwas gutes abzugewinnen
[Musik]
auch diese familie hat einen schutzwall
gegen das hochwasser gebaut von der
letzten überschwemmung sind sie noch
geschockt haus und garten stehen unter
wasser
momentan ist katastrophe kein wasser
kein strom kein heißes wasser wir sind
eben zwei dreimal losgefahren um zu
gucken das war baby milch oder
babynahrung bekommen wer zahlt das alles
wie kann es weitergehen
fragen die die menschen hier
beschäftigen und immer wieder der eine
gedanke sind alle am leben uns geht es
gut und das ist die wichtigste sache bei
der geschichte
das ist wichtig in der kiesgrube erb
stattdessen kamen heute auch taucher zum
einsatz
bisher konnten aber keine todesopfer
gefunden werden und aus erbstadt ist uns
nun der landrat des rhein-erft-kreises
zugeschaltet herr ochs sie haben heute
den bundespräsidenten und dem
ministerpräsidenten von
nordrhein-westfalen begleitet was nehmen
sie was nimmt der landkreis mit von
diesem hohen besuch
ja ich glaube der versuch war wichtig
und richtig
wir haben eine katastrophale
katastrophale lage hier vor ort und der
zuspruch des bundespräsidenten und des
ministerpräsidenten in den gesprächen
mit den bürgerinnen und bürgern und mit
den helfern vor ort sammelt kraftvolle
die hier unterwegs sind und die brauchen
wir dringend
armin laschet auch bundesminister
versprechen jetzt schnelle und vor allem
unbürokratische hilfe was erwarten sie
von den politisch verantwortlichen
konkret ich glaube wir sind ja in einer
phase wo wir noch immer noch leben
suchen
glücklicherweise im rhein-erft-kreis
noch keinen toten und in der zweiten
phase muss man gucken wie kann der
bürger und die bürgerin wieder in ihre
häuser zurück wie kann man verlust von
material auch ersetzen
hier gibt es eine hohe solidarität und
hilfsbereitschaft im rhein-erft-kreis im
kleinen hund in der dritten phase dann
wenn es darum geht gibt es menschen die
wirkliche not sind die alles verloren
haben
dann erwarte ich auch von der landes-
und bundespolitik gemeinsam mit dem
rhein erft kreis und der stadt erftstadt
dass wir gemeinsam anpacken und auch
diese not lindern und den erftstadt
bliesheim ist es ja zu gewaltigen
erdrutschen gekommen aber es gibt
bislang sie haben gerade gesagt keine
bestätigten todesopfer ist das jetzt
glück im unglück wie erklären sie sich
ja diesen hoffnungsschimmer mitten im
chaos
ich glaube das kann man schon ein stück
wunder nennen was hier passiert ist bei
all dieser katastrophe haben sich
anscheinend alle leute rechtzeitig
flüchten können aus dieser
krisensituation vor allem jahr hinter
mir auf der bundesstraße 265 insgesamt
28 fahrzeuge in kürzester zeit voll
gelaufen um wir haben zurzeit die
situation keinen vermissten keinen toten
zu haben
das grenzt schon an ein wunder dabei war
ja die flut in der tat sehr schnell
gekommen senken haben sich binnen zehn
minuten haben binnen zehn minuten unter
wasser gestanden das war also kaum zeit
die menschen zu warnen
welche lehren ziehen sie persönlich auch
als landrat für die zukunft aus diesem
buch wasser also vielleicht ist es für
lehrern noch einfach zu früh
wir müssen natürlich in und nach der
lage überlegen was wir verbessern können
die krisenstäbe der stadt erftstadt der
anderen städte und das kein erft kreises
in kooperation mit der bezirksregierung
in der landesregierung machen ihren ganz
hervorragenden job wir müssen dafür
achten dass wir zukünftig so eine
großwetterlage für so nicht herr werden
diese katastrophalen
jahrhunderthochwasser werden wir hoffen
sie sich nicht mehr haben und wir werden
ihnen auch nicht gerecht werden können
wir werden aber trotzdem an dem thema
kommunikation miteinander arbeiten
müssen und wir werden natürlich in der
nach analyse alles dafür tun dass die
dinge die vielleicht auch nicht gut
gelaufen sind in zukunft noch mal anders
beleuchtet werden
die ersten ansichten des landrates des
rhein-erft-kreises frankreich danke
ihnen für das gespräch und ihnen und den
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürgern im
landkreis alles gute vielen dank
da ja in erftstadt bliesheim sind
sämtliche rettungsaktionen für die
anwohnerinnen und anwohner inzwischen
abgeschlossen
170 menschen wurden unter anderem mit
hilfe von hubschraubern aus dem
überfluteten gebiet herausgeflogen
die dunklen stunden einer
naturkatastrophe sie ziehen ja auf die
hellsten stunden der retter nach sich
und so ist das auch in erftstadt wo in
der bald ist eine spektakuläre
bergungsaktion beobachtet hat
dies ist kein see dies ist die
bundesstraße bei erftstadt blessem seit
tagen dümpelnde autos und lkw durch den
dreck heute beginnt die bergung 30
fahrzeuge
niemand weiß ob vielleicht tote darin
sind rettungsschwimmer sind da und für
den ernstfall
taucha wir haben diese umgehungsstraße
die geografische besonderheit dass ein
mühlbach unterquert werden musste wir
haben also ein aquädukt einfluss über
eine straße führt dementsprechend tief
lag die straße und daher kommt es dass
die pkw teilweise zwölf meter unter
wasser liegen die bundeswehr hat viele
retter geschickt und vier panzer und die
sind nicht zimperlich es wird nicht
geborgen es wird weggeschafft der
gesamte ort messe im neben der straße
ist vom wasser unterspült worden häuser
ja der ganze ort rand wurde mitgerissen
so stieg auch das wasser hier auf der
straße in minutenschnelle als die autos
im stau standen
wir sind ja im urstromtal des rheins auf
sandboden und dass dieser sand man kennt
es vom bogenbauer der nordsee
[Musik]
1500 ps eines bergepanzer man kennt es
vom burgenbau an der nordsee das nasser
sand liest wie wasser die gute nachricht
die helfer finden nur schrott keine
toten die straße ist nun langsam
freigelegt aber für blessem ist dass
erst ein kleiner anfang normales leben
wird es hier noch lange nicht geben
ja in nordrhein westfalen sind ja 23
städte und landkreise von
überschwemmungen betroffen
in rheinland pfalz hat das hochwasser
vor allem den kreis ahrweiler getroffen
und dort ist eine gemeinde quasi zum
sinnbild dieser sinnlosen zerstörung
geworden denn die schuld ein traumhafter
ort der zum albtraum mutiert ist nicht
nur weil gebäude und infrastruktur
zerstört sind auch weil kinder und
jugendliche schaden genommen haben an
leib wie an seele
manche eine schaut trotz allem
hoffnungsvoll in die zukunft wirklich
alle in schuld packen mit an sich
ablenken nicht nachdenken müssen was
ihnen hier geschehen ist was braucht
auch die 14 jährige anna sie hilft
anderen obwohl sie selbst fast nichts
mehr hat so sieht das haus ihrer familie
jetzt aus das ist noch übrig
das ist auch das gesamte haus am herzen
weil er geworden gibt es sowohl
mehr will ich das einzige was da noch
war im rosa rahmen ein kinderbild von
anna ihre beine sind voller blutergüsse
und blaue flecken ganzes 40 hat sie
gezählt
ich habe am anfang versucht die
haushalte zu machen das hat gar nichts
gebracht
mir stand das wasser hüfthoch ich habe
nicht gesehen wo ich lange was das
schwimmen der grünen hat sich auch
gelöst ich bin gefallen sachen gegen
mich gestorben ihren kater den konnte
sie retten die kaninchen aber nicht es
ging einfach alles zu schnell sich daran
zu erinnern macht gänsehaut
anna ist erst 14 gestern wäre ihr
letzter schultag vor den ferien gewesen
[Musik]
das ist alles was zählt hört man hier an
jeder ecke froh am leben zu sein
nachdem das wasser sich durch den halben
ort gefressen hat behelfsmäßig gibt es
hier nun wieder eine straße drumherum
wird gebaggert die freiwilligen
helferinnen und helfer aus den
umliegenden dörfern waren sofort da als
allererste für anna jetzt noch viel
klarer als zuvor
sie will später mal zur feuerwehr wenn
man mal hochwasser ist oder was anderes
passiert möchte ich mit im einsatz sein
ihre sommerferien wird anna wohl hier
verbringen um ihr zuhause wieder mit
aufzubauen
ja seelische schäden sind schwer
reparabel verlorene menschenleben
unwiederbringlich aber materielle
verluste die können wettgemacht werden
bei mir im studio zdf rechtsexperte
felix zimmermann welche
versicherungsarten kommen denn jetzt
tatsächlich auf für die sachschäden tut
dass die gewöhnliche hausrat und die
hausrat deckt schäden an der einrichtung
ab und die wohngebäudeversicherung
schäden am haus aber die basisversion
dieser beiden versicherung die kraft für
naturkatastrophen wie hochwasser im
leider nicht da braucht man eben eine
zusatzversicherung elementarschutz
sanierung und auch in diesem fall geht
es auf das kleingedruckte zu achten
welche pflichten habe ich als
versicherungsnehmer hätte ich
vorsichtsmaßnahmen walten lassen müssen
also es ist keine selbstverständlichkeit
hier einsatzes werden sehr viele bürger
hier auf kosten sitzen bleiben kann denn
jeder haus- oder wohnungsbesitzer eine
solche zusatzversicherung für elementare
stellten bekommen also eine mit
bezahlbaren prämien die
versicherungsunternehmer sind ja nicht
verpflichtet verträge abzuschließen und
die gucken sich genau an wie welches
risiko besteht in dieser region und bin
da die statistik sagt achtung roter
ampel dann nur gegen sehr hohe prämien
versicherung oder eventuell sogar gar
nicht und das natürlich ein großes
problem für jemanden der da betroffen
ist dann gilt es dann vor dem hauskauf
zu gucken wie gefährdet ist denn
eigentlich
diese region und zweitens kann ich denn
an dem schaden schutz versicherung
abschließen wenn die versicherung nicht
zahlt kann man zumindest noch auf
staatliche hilfen hoffen
da sind einige angekündigt bis hin zur
sonder abschreibungsmöglichkeiten
was muss man dabei achten absolut also
wer jetzt sozusagen viel geld in die
hand nehmen muss um wieder aufzubauen
der kann diese kosten als
außergewöhnliche belastungen geltend
machen der steuererklärung und die
betroffenen länder und der bund haben
wirklich umfangreiche hilfsprogramme
angekündigt wenn wir zurückblicken
flugkatastrophe 2013 da waren damals
acht milliarden euro zusammenkommen
sogar mehr als man benötigte aber auch
ein klein wird jetzt geholfen der stadt
erftstadt sie gibt jedem bürger der
gesagt ich habe jetzt einfach kein geld
um lebensmittel zu kaufen
auf die hand 200 euro neben häusern
steht im katastrophengebiet auch vielen
autos das wasser förmlich bis zum dach
greift da die gewöhnliche kasko teil
oder voll da gilt der grundsatz wenn das
wasser zum auto kommt also das auto
geparkt war dann greift die
teilkaskoversicherung ersetzt den
schaden wenn er das auto allerdings zum
wasser fährt versehentlich auch dann
kiew die meistens nicht dann brauchen
die vollkaskoversicherung
na ja und wer absichtlich irgendwie grob
fahrlässig in ein übersteigertes gebiet
fährt der muss dann auch mit erheblichen
kürzungen rechnen
wertvolle auskunft unseres
rechtsexperten felix zimmermann danke
für den besuch hier im studio
ja diese zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
morgen wird sich auch die
bundeskanzlerin ein bild von der lage in
den hochwassergebieten machen aber was
die menschen dort sicher dringender
brauchen als politiker in gummistiefeln
ist unbürokratische hilfe die nicht nur
versprochen sondern wirklich auch
geliefert wird die chance es besser zu
machen als in der pandemie diese
gelegenheit haben bund und länder nun
und sie sollten sie nutzen das war unser
zdf spezial hier empfängt sie gleich
sabine heinrich zum großen deutschland
quiz ihnen noch einen schönen abend und
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]